une mode qui gagne peu à peu les six
dates un citadin part dans un jardin en
ville les espaces étant limitées et bien
c'est chardin sont dit partager exemple
vous allez comprendre tout de suite à
paris dans deux quartiers très
différents dans le 7e arrondissement
d'abord ensuite dans le 11e evelyne
goldman daniel levy
kashi dans le 7e arrondissement de paris
le jardin catherine labouré havre de
paix il est fréquenté surtout par les
habitants du quartier et par des
employés qui viennent y faire la pause
déjeuner les antilles côté intimiste
sympathique il est planqué dans les les
paquets de maison c'est
ce petit paradis est avant tout un
verger où poussent de nombreux arbres
fruitiers une tonnelle plantés de vignes
incite le visiteur à la méditation on y
trouve aussi un potager entretenu par
deux jardiniers qui le moment venu font
partager leur école
si on vient à certaines heures du jour
pendant la journée je sais plus
exactement quand volontiers il donne
d'autres
pour les petits parisiens qui ont
rarement l'occasion de voir pousser ce
qu'ils ont dans leur assiette
c'est une véritable découverte c'est
beau et fort
après ça devient tout rouge l'abondement
sévère la presse et déjà rouge s'allumer
encore une ici beaucoup plus exigus le
jardin nomade dans le 11e arrondissement
de paris fait à peine 300 m² il a été
aménagé en jardin potager par des
habitants du quartier regroupés en
associations ce sont eux qui le
cultivent pour 21 euros par enfant
voilà à mon petit fût siècle passé
l'hiver à l'intérieur c'est une petite
place l'arbre peut-être que c'est pas la
meilleure place du jardin
la plupart de ces jardiniers du dimanche
sont des femmes qui donnent leur vie
n'avait jamais manié la binette
c'est une découverte totale pour moi et
je connaissais pas du tout est vraiment
jeu
j'ai complètement adoré ça et je pense
que c'est parce qu'il ya un avenir futur
me réserve des plus grands terrains mais
en tout cas pour l'instant
il existe dans paris une quarantaine de
jardins du même genre de telles
expériences sont soutenus par la ville
de paris celle ci devrait durer encore
deux ans